attention va pas de blessé diane s'étend
de tout son sens
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu étais mon jeu je peux pas oublier
puis passé
je joue et je peux kuaté foisel
paris
comment sais tu pas sans s'indigner
as auprès de moi même projecteurs ses
costumes
et la plus belle ma croisés comme enjeu
moi j'ai passé c'est le passé
une autre niche va partir ce qui s'est
passé
je pouvoir rattraper le temps pour te
tue pas dites moi qu'est ce que j'ai
fait bon sang qu'est-ce que j'ai fait
mon sens c'est que le passé s'est passé
il ya 14 comme confier tu sais pas
on chasse samedi
après
[Musique]
jetons petit coeur ma chère tu es trop
séduisant
joujou sais pas si c'est passé
comme chaque jour
la ch'ti est pas
et philippe kappeler tout jeter mieux
c'est bon
dix jours et je te parcourir
c'est
du soleil aidé
[Musique]
je pense
il y a
[Musique]
les sensations
si donc
m
[Musique]
les sensations à temps
augmentation toutes les formes
cela fait éclater de la lite ça va des
côtes jusqu'à 6h du mat
j'entends les peintres l'est pas pour
les pompiers ils sont fatigués on est
fatiguée papa tig
[Musique]
solana voilà
soleil était là quand
et matinaux des matines à
mesquer
mais pas ça
y'a du soleil
[Musique]
émana
[Applaudissements]
db
j'aurais bien
[Applaudissements]
s'il était magique c'est pour moi c'est
pour moi le le gâteau
c'est un carton les soleils et nana ça
du tout et moi j'en ai une autre moi
j'avais découvert qu'il avait fait avant
elle virage à oui la musique ya quand
même deux ans et j'en regarde regarde
voilà chocolat et vous l'avez la musique
là je l'avais oublié